[Music]
what's important about that is that the
team feels like it is okay to bring
forward these possibilities without you
judging them without you firing them
without you deciding that they really
can't be part of the team because
they're challenging you how can failure
lead to success that's while seems like
it can be easy is one of the most
difficult things I think for leaders to
do
welcome to grit and growth from Stanford
seed the podcast where Africa and South
Asia's Intrepid entrepreneurs share
their trials and triumphs with insights
from Stanford faculty and Global experts
on how to tackle challenges and grow
your
[Music]
business I'm going to talk about
skateboarding for a second I promise
it'll make sense in a
minute
if you've ever watched professional
skateboarders you probably noticed
something interesting they fall
down like a
lot these are some of the best
skateboarders in the world why are they
falling so much well pro skateboarders
are constantly pushing the boundaries
creating new combinations doing more
flips or spins or whatever those tricks
are called and in doing so they
[Applause]
fail but that failure is key to their
future success without the Falls there
wouldn't be a 720 or a 1080 or a I don't
know a kickflip or
something failure has become a bit of a
buzzword in the startup World you'll
hear entrepreneurs talk about failing
fast or failing forward but clearly
failure itself isn't the goal so how do
you fail the right way what does that
mean and what a failure isn't an option
I think that if we have not created a
sense of psychological safety on our
teams and in our organizations we can't
expect people to embrace a learning or
growth mindset observant listeners will
recognize that voice I'm Sarah soul and
I'm a professor of organizational
behavior here at The Graduate School of
Business when Sarah talks about a growth
mindset she's referring to a way that
people think about themselves those with
a growth mindset believe that they can
improve their skills with hard work and
input from others
as opposed to people who think their
abilities are set in stone that they're
innate failure is key to developing a
growth mindset and I think that that's
really important because often times
particularly here in Silicon Valley we
talk about the importance of a growth
mindset and if we're going to fail fail
fast learn from that but of course we
know that failure is difficult my
daughter attended a high school that
lived this philosophy bombed your exam
hey take it again in in fact keep taking
the exam until you believe you've done
as well as you can do my son in contrast
went to a large public school where
every exam was one and done and now I
think about my kids today and my
daughter takes much more joy and
pleasure out of learning and the
challenge of learning than my son who's
sometimes resentful and often really
stressed out so how does that translate
into your workplace where you may not
get to take that exam over and over
again how do you make failure productive
to learn the right way to fail you first
have to recognize that there are in fact
different ways of failing that's been
the focus of researchers like Professor
Amy Edmonson who pioneered the study of
psychological safety there's mistakes
and there's mistakes right there's the I
overslept and missed the marketing call
and we lost our biggest client sorry I
think that's a great question and I
think some of Amy edmonson's latest work
begins to get at this so she's recently
published a book on the science of
failure and the right way to fail and
some of the things that she points out
in in that work I think are very
important to this question because we
need to distinguish between mistakes
that are made that should have been
preventable and these are made because
somebody has uh been inattentive or has
been sloppy or has just been going rogue
for some reason on something versus
smart failure it's important to have a
plan for this kind of failure because
it's bound to happen eventually
everybody makes mistakes as I myself was
reminded during this interview I did not
hit record oh but we have it here we
have here I'm going to start now I am so
sorry that's okay I broke the first rule
of podcasting I forgot to hit the record
button now don't worry everything turned
out fine because I had backups and
because Sarah is incredibly patient it
was embarrassing but ultimately fixable
encouraging a growth mindset with your
team may not prevent technical mistakes
but if everyone is on honest about what
went wrong it keeps those mistakes from
snowballing into disasters when we think
about the the mistakes and we all make
mistakes All Humans make mistakes but
what we hope is that when we have made
mistakes that should have been
preventable we do need to hold people
accountable for that and we also need to
make sure that they are willing to
report those mistakes because a tendency
of humans when we make mistakes is to
try to hide them and one of the elements
of psychological safety is that people
on a team don't hide their mistakes they
also feel comfortable and safe to
challenge their superiors to challenge
their colleagues when they see something
is about to go a miss so if I make a
mistake on the team rather than hiding
it I have a discussion with the team I
admit the mistake and importantly the
team tries to not Point their fingers at
me and blame me but talk about what went
wrong in the team and what went wrong
with the processes on the team that led
to that mistake leaders play a huge role
in creating an environment where it's
okay to admit your mistakes a few things
I think that are really important you
know one is establishing right away the
trust of the team and the right kind of
culture on the team when a new leader
comes into a situation often the
instinct is to sort of suggest here are
my values here is the culture of this
organiz ation and then to immediately
demonstrate the exact opposite with
one's actions and so for example I'll
give you an example saying one of the
things that I think is most important in
this organization is safety and then
when say a machine is down to come
charging in and saying when is that
going to be back up even if it means
that that would violate the principle of
safety and I think that that's one of
the things that's very important
particularly for for a new leader in an
established organization to come in
right away Express what the values what
the the elements of the culture are
going to be the expectations are and
then to continually repeat but also
demonstrate that that is what the leader
believes Sarah practiced what she
preached listen to how she reassured me
I am so sorry that's okay it just kills
me that I came in here with two backups
and still screwed this one up last time
too many too many too many too many
buttons
okay giving a calm and measured response
to failure can be just as hard as
admitting a mistake Sarah has an
exercise that lets your team practice
both these exercises come from the world
of improv but if you're going to do
these with your team pro tip don't use
the word improv because it scares people
just say we're going to try this it's a
it's a nice group team building exercise
okay the old good game is think about
all the times that somebody gives you
something and you have a response which
might be oh good not so great what you
want people to do in this exercise is
first no matter what it is that they
give you and it's imaginary you're in a
group or in a pair whatever it is that
they give you you have to say oh good
and tell them how you're going to use it
so I could say to you Darius here's a
pillow and you would have to say oh good
I'm going to have a pillow fight this
weekend something like that or I'm
needing to take a nap can people try to
mess you up by saying oh look here's a
six foot long slimy banana slug and
that's what you do in the second round
so the first round it can be neutral the
second round is you give something to
somebody that maybe isn't so great or
well in my hum here's a parking ticket
yes oh look here's a parking ticket and
they still have to say oh good and they
might say something like oh good I've
been U needing to write a check and I
haven't done it in three years finally I
get to go to court yes oh good I've
wanted to go to court or or here's a six
foot long or a six inch long banana slug
oh good I've heard that they make great
pets
okay so that's another way and what that
one gets people to do is to be
optimistic to be a little outrageous and
it can kind of lower some of the
barriers that we have on teams and it
also allows a leader of a team to
demonstrate that they too can be sort of
fun and it kind of levels some of the
hierarchical nature of a team that
actually strikes me as super important
because I'm always fixated on cultural
diversity because so many of our
companies are working across multiple
regions language groups casts and
religion and they often have us or
european staff or operations or sales
teams and then Sim similarly in
subsaharan Africa multicountry teams and
businesses and breaking down the
hierarchies that are established in
those cultures I think and especially in
cast could be really important
yes while occasional mistakes are
inevitable a culture of mistakes
shouldn't be you need to strike a
balance between acceptance and
accountability there's this saying that
you know if you really want people to
give you the hard truth you need to
celebrate the messenger now what if the
messenger was the one who totally
screwed up and you know at the end of
the day you have to decide who gets
promoted who gets a bonus there is
accountability if you're not holding
people accountable for their mistakes
your business is not going to really
Thrive so how do you celebrate the
messenger but also hold the people
accountable who are not performing again
I think it's important to note that what
Amy Edmonson means is that psychological
safety is a a characteristic of teams or
organizations and that refers to a
climate or culture or environment on
that team it's different than creating
safe space for people to uncover at work
which is also something that might be
important in some organization so I
think it's important to sort of
disambiguate those kinds of Concepts so
the concept of psychological safety
could actually lead to poor outcomes if
it's not also linked to accountability
and that's another framework that Amy
ebson talks about if you have low
motivation and low accountability and
high psychological safety then
everyone's kind of in a comfort zone
that may not necessarily be good for
business or innovation or risk-taking or
dealing with uncertainty and I think
what's clear to me at least in her work
is that leaders actually really need to
distinguish between those two and not
just sort of celebrate All failure
there's got to be some accountability
right
[Music]
right psychological safety can keep keep
one mistake from becoming many but where
it really shines is when you and your
team are trying to tackle what we call
adaptive challenges unlike technical
challenges these don't have a clear
answer solving adaptive challenges
requires brainstorming an open and
creative process that benefits from a
growth mindset there's something else
that the more recent research on
psychological safety is striving to do
and that is to look at the situations in
which this really works and the
situations in which it doesn't so I
think one finding in that literature
that's important is that psychological
safety has we get stronger effects in
these studies when the work itself is
not prescribed so knowledge work when
the work is more ambiguous and requires
a lot of collaboration to solve problems
psychological safety ought to be a more
important predictor of success when
we're tackling those kinds of adaptive
problems as opposed to okay you're the
sales team here's your sales targets yes
here's your list of potential customers
go out and produce absolutely exactly
and I think increasingly a lot of our
work does uh fall into the category of
these more adaptive challenges and so we
ought to be thinking pretty seriously in
those situations of how we can promote
psychological safety in adaptive
challenges failure isn't accidental it's
part of the process I think part of that
is about making sure that when we are
making small or larger bets when we're
building new strategy when we're
thinking about a product launch what we
need to be thinking about there is all
of the work that's been done to build
the hypothesis that this thing could
actually work and to mitigate some of
the risks and that as we think about
smart failure if you've done all of that
and you try this and it fails at least
at that point you can have an open
discussion about what you've learned so
there's got to be both error reporting
and accountability for the preventable
mistakes a lot of work done to really
think through the con consequences of
our big new innovative ideas so that
when and if we do fail or fall short of
what we hoped we can learn from that and
what's important about that is that the
team feels like it is okay to bring
forward these possibilities without you
judging them without you firing them
without you deciding that they really
can't be part of the team because
they're challenging you that's while
seems like it can be easy is one of the
most difficult things I think for
leaders to do the other thing I was
thinking is that and I'm just reflecting
on my own experience here you know the
important debates are about an
unknowable feature so psychological
safety seems extremely important in
cases of great uncertainty but also
where business decisions have a lot of
interdependency so you need everyone on
board everyone needs to understand why
we're doing this why we're going that
way and the person who runs the factory
floor needs to give their input you know
great idea but guess what that doesn't
work on your your timeline and you need
everyone who every interdependent leader
needs to be involved in that
decision failure is hard to deal with
period let alone in front of your bosses
and co-workers so if your team isn't
prepared to fail Sarah has an exercise
to get them comfortable with being
uncomfortable it's called the shared
fake memory and what you do with the
group shared fake memory is that you
begin one person begins and you can do
this groups of three four five and
essentially one person might start and
they will say hey do you remember that
time we rode dinosaurs whatever they
want to say and in the first round you
instruct everybody's got to be part of
this and you instruct people to Simply
say things like well no actually we
didn't go to the library we went to the
coffee shop and then somebody else may
say well no actually it wasn't the
coffee shop that we went to we actually
went to a bar and then maybe somebody
will say yes and at that bar we ate
chicken wings and somebody else says no
it wasn't chicken wings we ate it was uh
spare ribs or something like that and
the point is in the first round is that
they're trying to create a story about a
shared fake memory but they've got to
like kind of disagree on some of the
details and then you bring them back and
have a little debrief on that exercise
and what they find is that maybe they
created a story about a fake memory that
they had together but more often than
not they kind of stalled out and they
didn't get very far then you send them
back together but with a different
prompt and that is don't disagree on the
details what I want you to do this time
is you have to agree on whatever the
person said and build on it and then
also at the same time if you have a
chance try to make the person who's the
protagonist of this story look good just
try to do that so the next time they go
in they create as a group their shared
fake memory then it's well you know hey
Darius do you remember that time that we
decided to go to Santa Cruz to the
boardwalk and then you build on that and
I can't believe you decided to rent
unicycles while we were there that was
so cool and aren't unicycles fun and do
you remember when we borrowed that guy's
parrot and put him on our shoulders and
it went back and forth between us little
did I know that there would be a film
crew there filming the whole thing for
Nightly News wow wasn't that awesome aw
and so the point of the second one is
that they they get a much more creative
group fake memory and they bond over
that and it's kind of exciting and
interesting so translate that into Team
Dynamics in the in the workplace so one
of the things that happens there is
you're building on each other you're
saying yes to somebody's idea you are
being creative and trying to amp up
creativity on the team and also
generally making people laugh and have
fun and that can be a great kind of
exercise experimentation is essential to
solving adaptive challenges but it's not
a luxury that everybody has so let's
translate that then into a team in a
mediumsized business in subsaharan
Africa and the team is faced with a
challenge new competitor is coming in it
looks like their offering might be
superior so this is what we would call
an Adaptive challenge not a technical
challenge how does growth mindset play
out on a team that's trying to rethink
their strategy and then I and I'd like
to link that back to what psychological
safety means or how it underpins or
promotes I don't quite I want to
understand the link between the two
concepts so I would say that and and let
me start with psychological safety the
first thing that I think is really
important to underscore is that in many
companies and I'll say that many of the
companies that I've had the honor of
working with in subsaharan Africa many
of them say well this seems like it
would never work here because we don't
have the mindset to be able to just
experiment widely and fail a lot and
learn from failure and we also don't
have the resources to do that often so
let's start with mindset are they saying
it's a cultural attribute of being in a
Pacific environment in Kenya or Tanzania
or India or something that's inculcated
through family values from childhood the
reason I bring it up is I used to work
on a program to promote entrepreneurship
in Guatemala we were encouraging
entrepreneurs to take risks and you know
the feedback we got was you know if you
fail your first business attempt to
autal you're kind of ostracized by your
family no one's going to you know and
it's all family and friend funding
anyway it's not like there's a bunch of
Bank funding for entrepreneurship in
rural Guatemala so once you fail you're
done right and so fail fast is not is
not like a great attribute of a business
you know test right yes and I think
that's a great question because I've
heard a couple of things I have heard
something akin to that it has to do with
resources but it also has to do with the
way in which people have been brought up
so that's part of it but I think the
other thing is is that many of the
companies at least that I've spoken with
about this are in Industries where
failure actually could mean that human
beings die so how do you feel smart if
failure is not really an option one of
the things that I think is really
crucial to understand is that in the
kinds of industries that Amy Edmonson
studied and you mentioned Airlines and
you also mentioned Hospital hospitals
right it's similarly the case but one of
the things that happens in these kinds
of organizations
is that people are allowed to fail in
simulations or simulator so airline
pilots for example have a lot of
training in a simulator and so they're
allowed to fail there and learn from the
failure in a way that isn't going to
harm human beings and similarly with our
most of our doctors and nurses there's a
lot of simulations that they go through
through their training which allow them
to fail but with a safety net and part
of why I think that that's important is
that it it has led in many Industries
such as those two to have discussions
openly about failure in a safe
environment the other thing not who
failed but why did we fail exactly not
who failed no blaming but why did we
fail and what can we learn from that so
that when we are in these high stakes
situations the incident of failure will
be lower and so I think that that is
something that some of our companies
some of the seed companies can learn
from first understanding and studying
and having some very good hypothesis
about what might lead to failure and
then secondly having simulated safe
experiences so that one can learn from
that another way to fail safely is
through a premortem exercise we fear
getting it wrong because we fear the
unintended consequences so imagine the
very worst case scenario from your
decision and think through what actually
went wrong premortem are a very actually
structured but simple
way of understanding you know what when
you're about to make a decision to say
launch a new product bringing the whole
team together to pretend that this has
failed massively it's two years from now
and it was a terrible mistake and then
to really think very hard about what
were the reasons for this failure and
then brainstorm ways that those reasons
could be averted as a way to prevent the
failure from happening so even if you're
not in the airline industry or have the
resources to have kind of a safety net
of failure one can do this through some
pretty I think effective team processes
like the premortem yeah I find the
premortem is fascinating Stanford seed
were contemplating expanding to a new
geography and so I took that idea of a
premortem and we said okay what could go
wrong and we categorized those as risks
and we assigned to them a probability
but also an impact weight and it allows
us to focus first of all there was a lot
of a lot of things that go wrong that I
couldn't have thought of one came from
our general counsel one came from our
Director of Finance you know those are
not my specialties but actually that's
where the greatest risk is right it's on
legal and finance right but we ranked
all those risks and we that gave us an
opportunity to say okay let's focus on
these four these four things have to be
true or this project fails now it still
might fail but at least we'll go in
there with our eyes open knowing what we
need to test and there's something about
the proram exercise which allows you to
in a safe way test those assumptions
before you make those big bets just
don't forget to also Imagine success
first of all it was kind of depressing I
will admit because you're coming up with
all the things that could go wrong so
one piece of advice I have is if you do
a premortem end with something like a
conversation about what happens if it
goes right like have a reason great idea
yeah have a reason to want to continue
right yes great
[Music]
idea every organization will encounter
failure whether it's through simple
everyday mistakes or tackling unknowable
adaptive challenges a growth mindset
removes the stigma from failure it
allows employees to think outside the
box and keeps small mistakes from
becoming big ones but smart failure is
hard leaders have to pave the way create
an environment where experimentation is
celebrated build on people's ideas
instead of shooting them down and praise
the messenger otherwise employees will
never give you bad
news also don't abandon accountability
consequences still exist within a growth
mindset they ensure that you learn from
mistakes instead of just getting into
bad habits if you don't have the luxury
to fail fast find a safe way of
simulating failure like a premortem
exercise just remember to focus also on
the positives not just the negatives
because learning to fail can ironically
lead to success and with all of those
kinds of great benefits what we see is
that team performance increases that
creativity increases that resilience
increases and we get higher levels of
[Music]
innovation stay
CM I'd like to thank Sarah soul for her
expertise and her insights and most of
all for being patient when I
failed this has been grit and growth
from the Stanford Graduate School of
Business I'm your host Darius Teeter if
you like this episode follow us and
leave a review on your favorite podcast
app Erica amake AJ and VN virgin
researched and developed content for
this episode Kendra gladich is our
production coordinator and our executive
producer is Tiffany Steves with writing
and production from Andrew ganam and
sound design and mixing by Alex Bennett
at lower Street Media thanks for joining
us we'll be back soon with another
episode
[Music]